hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Marcus Tullius
Cicero is work on friendship one of the
things that he's going to do really on
in the work putting this in the mouth of
the character Laelius who was an
existing human being is to try to
provide a definition of friendship now
this is gonna be friendship in the
fullest and truest sense not just
anything that we happen to call
friendship and we'll talk about that
point a little bit later that's a very
important thing to keep in mind before
we do that though there there's two
things that I want to bring up that help
provide a little bit of context here so
the first thing is that Laelius is owned
companions which are presumably his
friends as well ask him to provide a
discussion of friendship they're
confused about it because it is a
confusing matter so the funniest says it
would be agreeable to me and to sky bola
too if following your usual practice on
other subjects when questions concerning
them are put to you you would discuss
friendship and give us your opinion as
to its theory and practice which is how
it's being translated here now Laelius
well that's not the easiest thing to do
he says I would raise no objection if I
felt confidence in myself for the
subject is a noble one but who am i or
what skill have I so he's saying this is
a complex matter he says in for a
subject of everything possible to be
said on the subject of friendship I
advise you to apply to those who profess
that art all that I can do is to urge
you to put friendship before other
things human
nothing is so conformable to nature
nothing so adaptable to our fortunes
whether they be favorable or adverse and
then after that preamble he goes into a
discussion about friendship and he will
give us a very useful definition the
other thing I wanted to stress from the
beginning is that they got into this
discussion because they were talking
about the great friendship that Laelius
enjoyed with somebody who he considered
to be his superior in many respects and
that is the Roman hero statesman general
and other things Scipio who has recently
passed away and so we have a model here
early on as well as other people being
discussed for what these friendships
would look like this isn't a purely
abstract discussion this is taking some
people from that historical context this
is happening in narrative terms a little
bit before the time that Cicero is
writing this by several decades but it's
it's still going to provide some context
to the readers of that time and so we
might well imagine people of our own
time where we've seen something like
this going on so with all that said
let's now look at the definition that
Laelius who's just begged off talking
about this topic is going to provide so
this is at the beginning of chapter six
he tells us that friendship is nothing
else than an Accord in all things human
and divine conjoined with mutual
goodwill and a
faction so we should look at each of
those parts in turn so it's nothing
other than an accord or we could
translate this in other ways the Latin
for it is consents EO and whenever you
have this con that means sort of
togetherness sense EO is coming from
said tra to to have an understanding of
to perceive and so friends have a kind
of accord or agreement or they see
things the same way we often say people
are on the same page this is central not
just to Cicero's conception of genuine
friendship but to earlier conceptions of
friendship as well including that of
Aristotle to whom you can see this
theory of friendship clearly indebted
and by Aristotle I mean the discussions
in Nicomachean ethics books 8 and 9 and
the corresponding discussions in the you
Demian ethics so an accord an agreement
a we might even go further it's a
harmony or Concord in all things human
and divine so according to this it is
wouldn't just be about beliefs this
would also be about actions we could
think about divine in the time of Cicero
of course this has to do with the
understanding of traditional Roman
religion but also perhaps philosophical
conceptions of the gods that are less
anthropomorphic and so Cicero is saying
when it comes to these transcendent
matters what's really best in life what
is you know responsible for the world
being the way that it is whether there
are gods or not there has to be a kind
of agreement and then also in matters
human this doesn't mean that everybody
has to have exactly the same you know
ideas about table setting or the same
tastes and music or the same Netflix
queue or anything like
but there has to be some sort of basic
commonality where the people are on the
same page so you know what would be some
examples of things that could disrupt
that well if one person is into snuff
porn and the other person isn't that is
going to be a deal breaker right there
isn't going to be a friendship there
actually sister would probably say
people who are into that sort of thing
not going to be good friends no matter
what they've got other problems going on
but we could think about all sorts of
other you know less ridiculous examples
you know the how one ought to spend or
acquire money child rearing politics all
of these sorts of things can bring
people together or separate them and the
the accord could not just be perhaps
about the content itself but also about
how people discuss it quite often
relationships will break down when there
is a lack of agreement about what's
actually going on when people disagree
with each other and if that happens
often enough that can damage what he's
calling friendship here now he also says
that there's two other things involved
here and these are really important
terms as well conjoined with is just a
translation of common latin meaning with
so the conjoined is a little bit
aspirational but you don't have to worry
about that too much
mutual good will been avowal entia this
is really essential and again this was
in Aristotle's classic treatment of
friendship in his case he talked about
friends feeling mutual goodwill towards
each other and what does goodwill it is
desiring good for the sake of the other
without anything necessarily
self-interested in your own part being
the origin or the direction or the
orientation of that so when I hear that
my friend has got a new job I am happy
for them because I want them to have
productive remunerative interesting
meaningful work right so
or at least to be able to put food on
the on the table if it's not a great job
or anything like that I don't worry
about whether that means they can buy me
presents or cookies or whatever I am
focused on the good of the friend and so
this is absolutely part of friendship
for Cicero and now notice the next term
and affection cadre Tata here in in the
ablative case Caritas is the nominative
case for this and if you have ever
wondered about you know pagan authors
versus Christian authors and there's
this idea that well with Christianity we
suddenly see a new kind of love which is
translated you know from the Greek agape
alright well in Latin that's usually
Caritas and here we see that that Cicero
thinks that Caritas affection love for
the other is absolutely central to
friendship some of these ideas about you
know pagans and Christians or the
different kinds of love that are very
schematic are quite often off base and
in the case of this work that is
certainly the situation so affection
mutual goodwill and agreement these
three things together compose friendship
there is something else that he says a
little bit earlier in Chapter five that
I think is quite relevant about goodwill
so I'm gonna read the passage here he
says that friendship excels relationship
in this in that goodwill may be
eliminated from relationship well from
friendship it cannot since if you remove
goodwill from friendship the very name
of friendship is gone if you remove it
from relationship the name of
relationship still remains so what what
is he talking about there so been a
volunteer willing good to the other
person it can be there or might not be
there
in what we're translating as
relationship pearl pink we toss right a
degree of being connected with another
person this could be being a neighbor
which is what propinquity ah suggests or
it could also be family members people
sometimes say well you could choose your
friends but you can't choose your family
you're kind of stuck with them is the
idea there and very often we can see
that families remain connected together
even when they're lacking goodwill
sometimes when they have malice towards
each other same thing with your neighbor
you can live next to your neighbor and
hate their guts but you still live in
the same neighborhood together don't you
but with friends if you lack goodwill as
Cicero saying that removes the
friendship now what you might say what
is this business about the name itself
he says subrata an inn been a volunteer
I'm a kitty I know Manto lead tutor
right and by name or no men there he
means something like the the genuine
description of what's going on so when
we take goodwill out of friendship we
don't really have friendship anymore
another thing that he tells us that's
quite interesting is is that friendship
is quite possibly the best thing given
to human beings now again friendship
when it has these three interpenetrating
elements to it accord mutual goodwill
and affection friendship in the sense of
just being plain old friends with
somebody because you knew them from high
school and you correspond on facebook
every once in a while and like they're
posted not so much right that's not that
big of a deal but a really good
friendship and a really good friend in
that friendship are among the best
things that we can enjoy now I want to
specify as we we bring this to a close
that Cicero tells us this has to do not
with every kind of friendship but with
what he calls pure and complete in Latin
perfecta brought to its
it's complete fulfillment or you could
say not not having any sort of blemish
so pure and complete friendship not the
ordinary friendships that we often have
in mind he says that there's a lot of
things that pass as friendship and get
called friendship that aren't actually
such and then he he tells us another
thing that also comes from Aristotle
that I think is quite valuable to to
examine he tells us that the true friend
is actually a kind of image of the self
and the Latin there is Tom qualm
exemplar Tom qualm is sort of a you know
the intensification tells you well sort
of it's not exactly an image of the self
exempt them all right a copy or
something like that but it's it's quite
similar to to that and so it's
interesting here too it's natural to
read it as the friend being an image of
oneself this role uses the term soui in
in there and the latin and he says
whoever looks upon intuitive right the
friend looks upon a certain image of the
self of oneself but we could also think
about it this way and so here's a
suggestion that goes a little bit beyond
the text when one looks upon the friend
in friendship in these important
dimensions of Beneful entia and Caritas
right maybe one is not just looking upon
an image of oneself but an image of what
the self in oneself and the friend could
indeed be we often talk about our better
self and I think that that would
correspond quite well with with the way
in which Cicero here is
helping us to understand what genuine
friendship would indeed look like
you